[Music]
and don't sweat it news
don't sway I never sweat it sometimes
like sometimes actually you're sweating
right now
submitted by dancing queen queen okay
a new study suggests that people like
you more than you think
this is the best news I've had all day
wow that's impossible
cuz I think everyone loves me but I know
i hella people want to kill me who was
the killer can haters we actually don't
have as many as I thought we should do
to a lucky I was scared the first time I
did like a badge of JK users y'all cuz
we did a JK party like with Smosh can't
use all the comments for like our fans
our Roasters but then they're actually
no they like they like what they like
I'm like that's they're just honest
exactly but they're not malicious like
certain other people's fans like or or
sometimes like I make friends with
people I'm cooler friends and a my mind
I'm like they like me and then I text
them and they don't text me back and I'm
like I thought we were friends and we
had a connection but they were just
being Hollywood or something when they
want something from you they gotta
[ __ ] butter you up for 30 minutes oh
man hey congratulations on all your
success
oh man we should always bet we gotta
have some coffee yeah we gotta make a
video together man all this stuff oh and
then at the end they go so where's that
location you used I want to use it it's
like [ __ ] wasted 29 minutes of my time
more they do the thing where they plant
the seed where like when you when they
see you about to blow up they're like oh
let me like get back in there and just
do a check-in you know well Hollywood
check in and they just want plain to see
you unless you thinking they're still
there and then like they come they come
back in hot later I don't like that I
like that at all yeah I enjoy your
company or let's catch up cool that's it
alright so this research there was this
research I was published in the Journal
of psychological science and it found
that people often underestimate
me how much another person likes them
after they meet for the first time
how about overestimate no I think I do
that sometimes
and then you checks them right and so
those that the check myself with Bart
and then I'm like oh wait maybe I'm
thinking they're really hype and then
like we had this really cool connection
but they're probably like oh god dad
you're such a [ __ ] I'm like oh [ __ ] for
your Thursday impression yeah yeah cuz
sometimes I just feel like there's this
really dope connection my dad that's so
tight it's her so cool man we got so
much in common isn't that like you do
that too yeah like for example one that
was true was me and Joel met David at
the San Diego Film Festival long time
ago and we hit it off he'll look good
right well Anthony - it's so crazy
Anthony - from kynges and we came back
the week of I would just text and then
they texted me right back I'm like cool
that was a legit connection yeah that's
like after you [ __ ] and you don't text
them back
you know you were just used yeah but
sometimes yeah you meet someone you're
like oh man we had it was dope we had a
dope connection are we gonna be real
homies in the streets now and you text
them and when i text you right back
streets and they don't text you and
you're like mother [ __ ] you didn't
like me it was just because I was the
only one there so you had to be friends
do you mean when I met you the first
time I felt like you in a really good
first impression yeah I liked you yeah I
still like I'll be like handing the
[ __ ] yelled at me I leave comments
you do you do we DM so it's like more
personal yeah I gotta get a reason to DM
you are you gonna watch your stories
right
me all the time and he's super funny I
don't watch any stories and I don't make
my own I got to start doing that I don't
watch any stories either I rarely watch
I'm more of a post person I like looking
at people's posts and reading their
captions yeah you don't like reading
captions no I'm not a reader I'm a
picture looker oh you don't see me
scroll like I just go fast you're like
wow that's all I read the caption I'm
like oh I don't care about those right
in the captions are people are good with
their captions so for them I do give
them the time but you get back even if
it's not like poetic or whatever it's
still an art form for you yeah and I'm
glad you appreciate but sometimes I'll
see a dope picture right and I'm like oh
[ __ ] and I scroll up and they don't even
have a caption oh my god you're gonna
uncap you're gonna caption this you know
it's like when people don't put a bio in
their tinder profiles like oh you think
that you're just good enough you think
you don't need my approval
I appreciate you know what that means
because sometimes silence is loud yeah I
don't like that I'm like you don't
remember that saying a picture is worth
a thousand words well what are the words
Israel is usually [ __ ] me or don't [ __ ]
me I need to know that you care about me
enough to say something to me but that's
their own photo album why should they
entertain you like a clown like who do
you like what I'm posting for you both I
think I'm biased because any time I've
run into a dude that didn't write a
caption on it or didn't like write it
about me on his tender bio he's dead oh
he was like this is good enough
take me take me as a personality because
I have faith I'm facing a huge [ __ ] like
Instagram oh yeah yeah I've been that
bled into Instagram
yeah a blood into Instagram it's the
same thing what works like that to you
for me the reason why I don't like it is
because sometimes I look at a photo I'm
like oh that's so dope where are they or
what are they doing or what it was
happening
and there's just nothing but what if
that's our intent to confuse you
I don't like everyone's an artist the
art is to convey everyone's art and
artists to me so I'm like oh is that
what you're trying to do well I am
confused Congrats I think I think it
bothers me because sometimes it comes
off as pretentious but when I think
about it that wasn't their intent
they sometimes people just don't know
what the [ __ ] to write or I feel the
opposite can I see that there's this
post and then there's an unrelated
caption I'm like thats [ __ ] trying
not to be pretentious
who do you I see what you're doing go
make your clothes like that it's like
levels level you could read through the
boo [ __ ] sometimes you could see it
right like Dave I love the inspirational
[ __ ] yes
like David Byrne blasts all the time
like oh I'm so scared about the people
and whatever they're going through and
it's like their naked eyes like come on
just leave your naked ass there we don't
need the [ __ ] caption appreciate that
no I agree if you're gonna post a
picture of your butt and just let the
but the butt can speak Buddha can speak
you know like yeah I appreciate that
yeah I get that that's true I mean
that's why I don't post that often
because for me I caption is important
cuz I'm like I don't know what to say
about this photo so I'm just gonna post
it you know I just I don't post a lot
because I don't like taking pictures of
myself yeah I don't like yeah I hate it
what about things like a horse or
something lately nobody wants this
nobody cares about that you know I like
it Oh Oh cutie I'm a big fan of horses
you know what gets me to like people and
want to be their friend is like it's
like they're doing something that I want
to do to like if they're fishing or
whatever I'm not oh it looks like fun
maybe I could be their friend we can go
together you know how many of those
friends do that I made a handful of
friends like that like our gum buddy
yeah and then like hobby buddies yeah
yeah last and then yeah it's like if
someone is horseback riding and [ __ ] and
I'm like some horses too but yeah but
see y'all are like I feel like y'all are
different and a lot of people that I met
in the YouTube sphere like y'all they
say that about us a lot ya know y'all
like legitimately like very real like
your very real people like when you're
sitting here we're all talking and stuff
like this [ __ ] is like really you know
but like so many other people in the
spirit like its they're putting up a
facade
oh really they're like really yes all
the time so like I like I don't know I
get that it's just it's a lot different
like being here is like a lot different
than like oh well thank you that's why
Steven Nikki said that they like this
because you know they're they've been in
YouTube for a long time and they're like
yeah it's like you're a brush of breath
of fresh air but that's how I feel about
Smosh too is like you guys are just
chill like just chill normal people that
just play games and then I'm like
there's no angle there's no like trying
to get more popular or like whatever you
just like having fun and I'm like I got
into this space for that reason to be
real to have fun so I don't have to
[ __ ] be a faker mm-hmm like you know
or else I would have been in Hollywood
so back to this research here so what
they did is that they got participant to
rate so they had these people meet for
the first time so first impression and
after their conversation it would last
for like different amounts of time and
then sometimes they had like a topic
starter or sometimes they didn't and
then after their conversation they would
each rate how that person did and then
how you think you did and then what they
found is that there was this liking gap
because they thought that that person
like when they rated what they think
that that person thinks about them like
whether they like them or not they rated
it way lower than with that person Rico
so I wished I would have taken this test
it's like he loved me he loved me he
loved me
oh [ __ ] yeah no I just feel like I have
a good way with people and I know how to
make people happy and I know how to make
them sad
you're a people person dude you're
awesome I thought this article was just
gonna say like study finds at America is
a lot more insecure than we thought
that's what it sounds like that's good
because people should be kept keeping
themselves in check like you should feel
like I'm not sure if I if I nailed that
because I don't know if everyone was
overconfident in all the time they might
be annoying [ __ ] yeah you know I want
people to like be a little afraid of
whether it's like somebody likes them or
not you know like knock them off their
high horse a little bit yeah he's gay
it's really simple to make people feel
like they like you it's really easy what
are the top three things you do you make
it about them so you make them talk
about themselves
a lot of people don't do that yeah it's
so annoying you know why cuz most people
go into situations worrying about
themselves a lot I mean am I good enough
am I gonna impress them am I like you
mention that in this yeah so so when you
go into these situations people get so
nervous about how they present but then
it's two people that are nervous about
themselves right but if I go into it
seeing it as a service to others like
like oh like let let me know about you
like I'm not here to [ __ ] tell you all
about me like let me tell you about like
let me let me ask about you and if
people get happy like oh I've done this
I've done that or whatever and then
that's that's basically oh you mean LA
yeah but then in LA it's the opposite
people be like I've worked with
so-and-so and that's when I go I know
how to make you sad oh that's it damn
that sucks serious yeah I'm like damn
that's like a wedding singer dude Oh
somebody's like oh I got to work with
the rock last week like wow how many
scenes did you dude is it yeah it's just
one I'd be like cool oh you know Dwayne
Johnson 2 wrong
I don't watch [ __ ] circus acts you
know what yes he's my neighbor you want
me to text them like I'm with you right
now does he know who you are
name-dropping
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]